Hello, and welcome back to the complete guide
to Teleport here at the Rawkode Academy.
In this second tutorial, we're gonna take a
look at using Teleport provided container images
and running Teleport locally on your own machine
using Docker for Mac, Docker for Windows, or
any container runtime on Linux distribution.
We will also explore using Docker Compose to
provide a lab like experience using some custom
images provided by Teleport as well.
We've got lots to cover today. There'll be
a whole lot of fun. Let's get started.
So as we do on these courses, we're
going to rely on the projects and documentation
as much as possible.
Let's jump over to Teleport's documentation right now.
Perfect.
So as we can see here, we have
an entire page dedicated as a to running
Teleport with Docker, which is great for us.
We can see that the images are hosted
on kuai.io and we have access to a
seven image, which is an alias to the
latest version of seven. X release,
but of course semantically versioned and tagged images
are available if that is a route that
you wish to take and one that I
would definitely encourage as much as possible.
Now there's one major difference from what happens
with Teleport running and a container image versus
the installation methods that we used on bare
metal machines on Red Hat, Debian and any
other distribution using curl.
If you watched the first tutorial,
you'll notice that we didn't configure Teleport in
any way. We just installed the package
and allowed the systemd unit fail to run
Teleport.
When this happened, Teleport detected that there was
no configuration and generated one for us.
However, we will not get the same experience
when running the container image.
Let's take a look.
So instead of starting with these commands, we're
just going to copy
the image name.
And if we run over to a terminal
and do a Docker container run dash rm
dash it, and we run this without any
other parameters, what we're telling
Docker or any other container runtime to do
is to pull this image and run everything
by the default.
This would be the entry point and command
specified inside of the Docker file or the
tool that we choose to generate it.
When we run this for the Teleport container
images, it's going to exit and tell us,
Hey, there was no configuration.
So the first major difference is in a
container environment, we must provide an explicit configuration.
And we're going to take a look at
how to generate that now also using the
same container image.
So the Teleport binary does ship with a
configure command, which will
print out a base configuration for us to
use. However, we may also want to understand
why this behavior is changed and we can
actually inspect the container image to see what
is going on underneath the hood.
If we do a Docker image and specs
passing in the image name, we'll be able
to see all the metadata from this container
image manifest.
The one that's important to us as the
entry point and the command, because we want
to know what the default actions are.
Now let's just quickly jump to the command,
which we can see is null.
And then the entry point, which we can
see
they're using a package called dumbinit, which is
an init system built for containers
to run Teleport Star and a very explicit
dash C pointing to a Teleport configuration.
So we could bypass this behavior by overriding
the entry point and calling our own Teleport
Star,
allowing the container image to generate that config
for us.
And while this works,
this is not really a great approach
because
that configuration is now inside of a running
container and should this container restart or stopped,
we are gonna lose it completely.
So in a container environment, we definitely want
to be able to pass in or mount
a configuration
file directly
or even both build and ship your own
custom images with that config.
I'd probably refrain from the latter for a
flexibility point of view, mentioned it at runtime,
it's going to open up possibilities to migrating
to
Kubernetes,
for example.
So we're going to cancel this and not
use that approach.
So let's take a look at modifying the
command that we just ran.
Well, this time instead of start, we're going
to use that configure sub command I mentioned
a moment ago.
And now we have a base configuration that
we can save locally for today's tutorial
and use and tweak as we move forward
with the exercises.
So I have copied and pasted
the config from the configure command
and saved that locally as teleport. Yml.
There is just going to make one change
to this configuration
and that is to remove the node name
from lane two.
This can be inferred by teleport at runtime
from the host name of the container or
machine that this is running on.
Okay, so let's jump back over to the
documentation.
Now that we have our default configuration,
we want to be able to run Teleport.
We're going to copy
this command to run Teleport
and to Versus Code
and make one or two modifications to get
started.
So something that has become a bit of
a rule at Rawkode Academy
is that we never ever name containers.
This becomes a piece of global state that
I am not really comfortable with in my
environment, so I'm going to immediately discard
name
Teleport.
We have two volumes being provided to the
container, one for the state of Teleport, which
is the environment Teleport and the other for
the configuration that we need to inject into
the system.
We're going to modify these in just a
second, but let me run over the other
flags first.
We have a few ports being exported or
exposed, sorry, to the whole system. 3,080 is
for the web UI,
3,025
is actually used for node communication, node SSH
communication within the cluster. So if we wish
to add other containers with other members, this
would be really important.
And 3,023
is the actual SSH port required for clients
to connect to the Teleport cluster.
So let's come back to our volumes.
I'm not a fan of using arbitrary directories
in my home file system again, because I
don't want any sort of global state and
I include file system as part of that.
So we're going to modify this to be
PWD
slash teleport.
Yml and make this path rather explicit too.
So this is going to pull through shell
interpolation,
my current working directory
and the teleport. Yml available there.
Now for
the state within a teleport system, I don't
want to mount that to a local file
system. So instead I'm going to use Docker
volume,
create teleport
data.
This gives me a named volume where a
state can be persisted across container restarts and
even recreations.
We provide the named volume name and see
that we wish to mount it to this
location.
I can now copy and paste all of
these commands or both of these commands
to my terminal.
We'll see the volume as created
and we should get a container running with
the configuration that we need.
Now we can verify that this is correct
by browsing to local host on port 3,080.
So new tab, local host 3,080,
add HTTPS.
This is in Chrome, it's Firefox system, so
we don't have to type this as unsafe.
We can do advanced
and accept.
And we now have the Teleport UI ready
for us to log in.
Okay, so there is one more thing I'd
like to cover in today's tutorial and that
is using Docker Compose
to provide a multi node configuration for Teleport,
as well as I use to explore all
the features available in the Teleport package.
Let's jump back over to the code and
I'll show you the changes that I have
made to allow this to happen.
The first thing that I have done is
create a Docker compose.
Yaml file.
I've defined a couple of volumes, one for
the certificates
to live in, which will be shared across
all the nodes in the cluster
and data,
which will allow the Teleport server to store
the state in a persistent manner.
The first thing we configure is the Teleport
server and you'll see this is very similar
to what we did previously.
We're using the Docker CLI.
We mount our server configuration,
our data volume and our certificates.
Now, in order to make this a
one command and up Docker compose environment, I
have added a health check,
which is going to periodically every two seconds
run TCTL status. TCTL status will exit zero
when the server is healthy and non zero
when it is not.
This allows us to have a dependency on
node one and node two.
These containers will only be started after the
Teleport server is happy, which will limit and
remove most of the error cases that you
could see in such an environment.
If we take a look at our Teleport
server config, again, is very similar to what
we've already been working with. However,
I have added something called a token to
the off service.
Now this is just hard coded because this
as a lab style environment and should never
be deployed to production.
But what it says is that we allow
anyone with a static token of Rawkode Academy
to authenticate against our server on a proxy
and node basis.
This allows other nodes to join if they
have access to the static token.
I have also generated a Teleport client configuration.
This is very similar to the server one.
However, we have the proxy service disabled,
the off service disabled.
We've left SSH service on. We still want
to be able to connect to the other
nodes on the cluster.
And I have now provided the hard coded
token and authentication
address for the server.
So the off token is Rawkode Academy and
off server is Teleport Dash Server on 03/2025.
This is just the name of the service
and the Docker Compose file.
Now what should happen is I'm going to
go to my terminal, run Docker Compose up,
we should see the Teleport server start first,
become healthy, and then the other two nodes
come online.
Let's see what happens.
So we can see the server is created
first. We don't have any node yet.
That's the server coming online
and we can see the nodes, the different
colors from the container log starting to show
up,
which gives me a pretty strong indication that
this is now worked.
But don't take my word for it, let's
check.
So we're going to jump over to here.
We're going to do HTTPS
localhost
3,080,
and we get the web interface for our
Teleport server.
Now we haven't created a user yet, so
we do need to jump over to our
terminal.
I'm going to have to do Docker container
ls
and I'm going to execute into our Teleport
server,
which is this one here.
Container EXPC.
We just want
a shell.
From here, I could do TCL users, add
roles,
admin, logins,
root,
and I'll add the Rawkode user. This is
going to give me a link that I
can copy and paste
into my browser.
I just need to remember to change the
container ID to local host
And now we can set a password. So
let's just let
one password to take care of this. Teleport
lab,
my username is Rawkode and save.
Now I can
click on this and have it scan the
QR code.
And I also need to copy the password
to here,
my 2FA
into here.
And we have now created an account.
So if I zoom in a little bit,
I have tested this environment and the state
has persisted into the data volume, which is
why we have a few extra nodes and
containers here. Whoops.
But we can see that everything seems to
be working as expected. And in fact, if
we take a look at the container IDs,
we have CC9 and 1B6,
that I should be able to click on
connect
and root.
And I know inside of my container environment
running a Teleport client
as part of my Teleport lab environment.
Nice and simple, this code will be published
and a link will be in the description
so you can use this Docker Compose web
the configurations to try this out yourself starting
now.
Go have some fun. We'll be back with
the server access workshop
tomorrow.
I'll see you all then. Have a great
day.